welcome back to grandma and filtered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by the queen of the teens
stranger things star and now she's the
face of Pandora meets mini Bobbie Brown
[Music]
how are you good
well you are a queen back in your
homelands babes and we're here to launch
Pandora me which you've collaborated on
which amazingly also touched on the
themes of self-discovery self-expression
and I just want to know how do you
express your internal south through
fashion and jewelry would you say I like
keeping it simple and classy feels
elegant and feminine but I also do kind
of like that tomboyish vibe so for me I
do like like these these kind of things
cool like kind of boyish and I don't
know it feels kind of masculine even
though it's like a feminine vibe with
the with the charms anything comfy is my
style like I'm down I even today I was
like these look like pajamas I'm gonna
wear it I'm really into anything comfy
and you use it to say something about
what's going on your inner self as well
I'm kind of if I would describe my stuff
like I'm a cozy person I like to stay
warm I like to keep everything kind of
internal like everything I have like a
close knit friends and host family
everything like I like to be in my house
I like to be in my room watching stuff
like it sounds like kind of like a
hobbit like I think I'm like never go
outside I love the outside but I really
like to be cozy and warm and that's kind
of how I would describe at least my
nature as I try to be as warm as
possible and as welcoming and so I think
that's kind of like when I'm wearing
fluffy clothes people want to cuddle
because this collection is about
self-expression what is your and
self-identity what is your own journey
been like towards discovering yourself
would you say I mean it's constantly
evolving with me you know starting out
in this industry I started off with so
many views that I wouldn't I guess I
agree with now and I just I think it's
more like with the education that I've
been given like I can really learn more
things about Who I am as a
person what's going on in society today
and it's definitely shaped to me
differently and I feel like yeah I don't
know the more you read the more you
learn about has made me grow differently
and made me perceive things differently
I guess I mean we're also growing the
growth never stops growth never stops
for me like as much as I change I'm
constantly myself and in my way like I
don't know I couldn't really pinpoint
one thing I'm consistent
but I would say I'm always myself and
that's what keeps me consistent what
would you say has been like the biggest
moment that shaped you as a person on
that journey of self-discovery would you
say well I'd say a few years ago I met a
young girl her name was Olivia Larusso
and she had been diagnosed with cancer
and I got friends with her for a while
we then became best friends and we spoke
every day and then she sadly passed away
and ever since then I mean I'm best
friends with her sisters have twin
sister her family were very close and my
new beauty and skincare line called
Florence we have it you know dedicated
you know in memory of product about
Olivia and I think that one of those
like that's probably one of the biggest
things that shaped me as a person it
genuinely made me look around and be
grateful for everything I have
it made me grateful for not only my
family but like life itself and being
young and really embracing everything
you've got in this current moment and
then also trying to help other people so
I think that was probably one of the
biggest yeah shapeshifters for me and
also you kind of want to carry on
achieving if for her memory as well yeah
exactly yeah keeping her legacy living
on and and you know fighting fighting
for research it's it's so important and
I think you know get something it's
definitely inspired me to get out there
and do more because you want such an
empowering person thank you and you're
inspiring people across all generations
it's not even just you're inspiring
teenagers like I've heard some of the
things you spoke about before and I've
been so inspired by some of the stuff
you said it's made me kind of rethink
about my positioning on certain things
for sure but when you're coming to
Express
you're like in a voice it's quite scary
thing to do yeah no matter how old you
are but especially at your age how
difficult is that been for you it can be
difficult I mean not only just the fact
that sometimes it's just being a girl as
difficult but not only that it's
difficult being young I mean people can
really not take you seriously especially
in this industry it's very difficult to
get your point across be hard I'm put in
a situation which is you know sometimes
it's different as maybe a little bit
different than other other young people
but it's it's it's almost the same
situation you know I'm being watched by
everyone and basically every move I make
is being watched by everyone but but
actually it's not that quite it's not
that different in any way I mean there's
teenagers out there that are evolving in
themselves and they have to go to school
every day and deal with whatever they're
dealing with or whatever they're dealing
with at home and so for me we all face
the same complications it's it's how we
deal with them and how we react so but
for me I would say like it's scary for
me it's scary for me to express myself
at times but then there are moments
where I feel very empowered and I feel
you know like really great about myself
like when I produced
Enola Holmes I got honoured that title
you know honored not live like not
legitimately honored but felt like I was
so honored to have that title as a
producer and I walked onto set and
everybody respected me as a person and
just like it's a co-worker and I felt
really respected and I felt really I
felt like we were both treating each
other equally and it felt I felt very
empowered by then I was really moved and
so I feel like those are the moments
when I kind of sit there and I
appreciate you know what what it's like
to be treated the same because also it's
difficult if you're a child because
people will talk down to you
unnecessarily sometimes and then you're
like she standing up there and you're
like no I need to let my voice be heard
and that's such a powerful thing and
that's something you do with UNICEF
which is so incredible
it's all about bringing a voice to
children how important is that to you I
want my voice to be heard
and Greta thumb bag wants her voice to
be heard and you know all these amazing
young people I could think of you know
Malala yousufzai her voice wants to be
heard imagine the millions of kids that
want to be heard and they can't be
because they're silenced or they are
ignored or they they are looked down
upon for for maybe their age or their
gender whatever their circumstance is
I like that UNICEF gives them a voice
lets them have a seat at the table lets
them talk about what they're passionate
about it's so so so important to have
these these voices because ultimately it
will change the world and ultimately
world leaders will have to listen we are
the next generation it's gonna be us and
we're gonna be having to fix the
problems that you have created or you
haven't helped of helped fix ultimately
UNICEF gives a voice to young people and
I think it's so important because
sitting here right now what would you
say is the most pressing issue for you
and the younger generation today I mean
it's where do you really want to start
you know it's like you can go with the
fact that every young person including
girls mostly deserve to have an
education the fact that social media is
still allowing bullies it's still
happening that is is it itself you know
and then and then you've got climate
change which is literally the biggest
issue at all because without that no one
can have education without the world
nobody's gonna learn we need to we need
to start taking care of our planet in
the best way we've got some amazing
voices out there that are really really
fighting against this which I in total
support of but those I mean the probably
the biggest pressing matter right now is
definitely is climate change it's also
so hard because there's so many big
issues going on right now that we all
need to fight and sometimes it can get
very overwhelming as well because you're
like what do what do I actually stand up
how do i but how do I fit fit into this
you know for me like I've I support many
causes that are going on you know I
support protests that are going on or
you know something that's
you know amazing communities and things
like that I support them but there are
things that I will stand up and fight
for and for me I think everyone that's
treated equally in any situation format
school workplace that is what we need to
fight for you know it's that because
that literally affects me I can't I
can't watch someone being spoke down to
you know no matter who they are if
they're a two year old like I said if
they're 17 you know I don't I don't care
I we should all be treated the same way
no matter who we are as people so that's
probably something that rages me so I
tried to stay calm about it but but ya
know I feel like there are some pressing
matters that I feel really passionate
about but nothing I won't fight for also
I think when you were arranged about
something it gives you a power and it
gives you like yes like so I was just
watching
Greta Sundberg speech the other day and
you hear the passion and the drive that
she has in her voice and it inspires you
it makes you think about everything yeah
she's she has this this amazing tone to
her where she you hear in her voice that
she's struggling to even you know think
about what's going on to this world and
this is crazy
- you're surrounded by such an amazing
community of people as well and you have
so many amazing contacts who are feeding
your growth which is such an incredible
thing what piece of advice is someone
giving you that's really shaped you as a
person
my mum yeah just whatever happens will
happen like legitimately if something's
gonna happen
you've just got to let it happen you've
gotta let you've got accept it and let
it go and I've used that in every part
of my life you know if that's with a
friend if that's with you know my work
if that's with something that's going on
with me as a person whatever is
happening to me if I can't help and
change it if I can't then I have to
accept it and let it go and that's
something I've learnt which can be
difficult but ultimately
it's good for your salt oh my god that
big guy yeah you do because sometimes
you just have to do that for your own
self-care yeah it's just like certain
amount of toxic it gets too much at some
point and you have to realize that you
what you what every decision you make
has to be good for you which is young
yeah not for anyone else either I mean
there's that like I'm I'm not a people
pleaser but I love to make sure
everybody's happy yeah my mom says
ultimately you can't make everyone happy
you know so I feel like that my mum
gives some good good good advice it's
not original but yeah because also what
we're speaking about letting go of
things and like negativity and things
like that when it comes to social media
it's the most amazing platform that we
have today to mobilize people but
there's also a very negative element to
it as well with social media trials and
Billy's and things like that how do you
switch off from that and how do you
separate yourself from negativity
I mean I'm constantly switched off from
from social media I mean you know
there's a certain amount of love I have
for social media but I have realized
that actually like what I what I post on
social media is me I don't ever want to
post anything that doesn't feel like me
so until social media becomes a place
that I think is acceptable which is a
positive place to spread love and lie
and funny memes and like genuine just
love and appreciation for everyone and
when certain people are not allowed on
social media then oh that no no name no
names I will then I will then appreciate
social media but until that that becomes
a post more positive place less
political more fun light-hearted we need
to we need to appreciate that actually
like just the stuff that's going on in
the world we need to spread the message
it's very important to spread messages
social media is a great place to do that
but it becomes so hateful and and it
becomes so violent and aggressive and I
just nobody needs that no young person
needs that in their life especially on
their phone that they can just take
anywhere they they want so oh I love
social media I love my fans and I love
posting funny things but until it
changes a little that's what I'll
appreciate it
sometimes you just need a bit escapism
babe don't weigh just like let's get the
funny memes on let's just get let's
below
I love the relatable memes like the ones
I just see them and I just love it it
makes me so happy all about it ya know
is if you haven't got nothing you play
producer actress now you're a beauty my
goal
I mean hey take a day off no I am just
no I I love it I love every second of it
so funny everything I'm doing is because
I want to do it you know that's what I
love I'm in total control of everything
that I'm doing and I have the best
family to support me through that and
the best team to support me through that
three years ago I was like I want to
make I want to make beauty and skincare
for people that first of all can't
afford the bougie you know products that
you put on your face and second of all
things that are good for you like
actually good for you tested and that
makes you feel good about yourself
you're not like piling a bunch of makeup
on your face that you don't need to
you're already beautiful and that's what
I've wanted to make you know I was like
you need to look beautiful you need to
look beautiful you need to put
foundation on but I don't want to do
that like that was not what I was about
that was why I was well it's just
basically adding to the beauty you
already have it's scary to go into new
spaces because you never know how people
are going to react or if they're gonna
find you you know if they're going to
take you seriously it's so difficult but
if you have passion Drive and confidence
it will get you through it what you used
to empower you in those moments when you
doubt yourself
the tired nights where I just like
finished at 5:00 a.m. at work and go
straight to a lot a plane to go this
place like those are the things that I
appreciate and I say you know what I
deserve this I deserve to go and meet
these people and I deserve to go and
talk to my fans and I
deserve to go and on a vacation like
those things you have to look in the
mirror and say you know like thank you
I'm sure or somebody even my age that
have just done exams they deserve a week
to chill out like these people we need
like appreciate that rest and sleep and
all that good stuff is really really
really important especially as a
teenager it's the most for me to most
forming years oh my god yeah cassava is
not selfish no it's not thank you that's
what people need to realize that's on my
beauty and skin cats like self-care is
not selfish yes deliver that message yes
what would you say to the people out
there who watch this and we've discussed
loads of different things about
confidence overcoming confidence
discovering yourself and if someone was
like doubting themselves and who they
are as a person what kind of like
rallying call message would you want to
give to them I mean listen to Liz oh yes
I love ah so true because she just
empowers me and me I'm like wow wow look
at me I'm in my room I love it I'm like
I like when they're like she's like
checking my now like yes yes yeah I say
listen ELISA and look in the mirror and
and look at yourself and feel beautiful
it's hard it's hard but but once you get
there eventually Jenny you have to look
at yourself and feel beautiful inside
now I saw at Glastonbury it was like the
most and life-affirming moment for me
everyone same I love what you look at
that mirror and how you love your side
she's so sick she's so cool and she's an
amazing role model you're an amazing
writer just keep inspiring us BAE okay
great thank you so much for joining us
for another edition of glamour
unfiltered hosted by me Josh Smith and
joined by the incredible Millie Bobby
Brown and for more empowering people
such as Millie ding-ding-ding-ding-ding
make sure you subscribe to the glamour
UK channels now have you done it yet
babe you can have to do it straight
after this yeah you have to do it
[Music]